Harry Jaffa has this wonderful line that
um the West is is saved or revitalized
every time a human heart is saved from
The Dark Knight of nihilism and
relativism
um and this is kind of the premise also
of of of my book that you know you've
titled a book how to say the west and of
course you feel a certain trepidation
about like if people are going to look
to you for some political program or
some you know list of answers
um but the point that I'm I'm trying to
make in in the book which Marcus I think
you you get at really well is like you
know actually the you know the the
restitution the restoration of of every
human heart is the project of of the
West and I think the first step to that
because very close to everything we've
been talking about the first step to
that has to be
um some recovery of this of the validity
of symbols right of of the uh just the
fact that these are not kind of
arbitrary or accidental features of our
biology but are I think you use the word
primary John and that they are in some
sense kind of a Bedrock uh of of reality
and and you know this is I think
expressed very well in in the Timaeus
and kind of carried forth
um by by these Christian Traditions
you've been talking about
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
Welcome to our Christ my name is Marcus
today I'm joined once again my friend
Jonathan paggio he's been a great
inspiration to me in this channel
Jonathan is a professional artist writer
product speaker give workshops and
conferences all around North America he
teaches carving speaks and heart but
most mostly he explores symbolic
structures that underlie our experience
of the world through his YouTube channel
and his podcast his political he's
furthers the conversational symbolism
meaning and patterns and everything
movies the icons the social trends
FMA go off a script here with it and let
you know about some exciting news so
Jonathan and I are actually in the final
stages of organizing an event yeah with
Paul Kingsman with the Dr Martin Dublin
this June so keep an eye out for that
and you'll be able to follow up my
YouTube channel and on event Eventbrite
and book tickets there and I'll also be
offering other events one including
Calvin Robinson Roger and father Ben
Kelly if you enjoy this conversation you
might enjoy that that takes place in
London on the 11th of March at Calvin's
church and I'm also joined today by one
of my favorite podcasters Dr Spencer
clevin with a PhD in Classics Spencer is
the author of the new book how to save
the West he's also an assistant editor
of the German Review of Books and
American mind at the Claremont Institute
Spanish lettering expertise is aided
based on a lot of money languages
including ancient Greek Latin and Hebrew
there's a scholar who enjoys exploring
great works of literature he provides
valuable insights into today's world
he's also previously hosted young
Heretics and he's been snapped up now by
Theory wire so I suppose first um if I
might ask you both what have you each
found most insightful about the other's
work and what are some of the key areas
that you'd like to explore today I
suppose especially in line with
Spencer's new book if I may start with
you Jonathan well I haven't I haven't
had I've been after I haven't read the
new book but one of the things that I
found very interesting is that I met
Spencer only once I met him when uh I
was at the daily wire and um
it was really interesting because it
seemed like we were very much in line he
was quoting all my favorite passages
from Dante at me like what what like
what is this amazing and so I feel like
I think like we're we're like aligned on
a kind of cosmic vision and so I'm
definitely looking forward to exploring
that more with him and seeing you know
how he brings that into his his project
so
yeah
um I had that same experience Jonathan I
think it's the I think it was Dante and
Beatrice from the uh from from Paradiso
that we were discussing and it speaks to
the place where I think we share the
most
um and that is this notion of you know
you're so eloquent about the symbolic
and uh the way that we kind of
experience you know I think that we we
currently have these two kind of toggle
options in the public mind one is their
their subjectivity and there's
objectivity right and objectivity is
like the stuff that's out there and it's
hard and you touch it and then there's
the stuff that's in here and it's
arbitrary and subjective and
um I have really you know been insisting
in my dogged way that there is a a kind
of middle space between those two modes
of perception which is properly called
subjective in the sense that it involves
a subject right there's no such thing as
beauty without a percipient but it is
not chair it doesn't you know just come
out of our Pure will or what have you
talk about a lot about that in the book
and you and I were I think sharing about
your essay on the uh the Earth right
whether the Earth revolves around the
Sun or the sun revolves around the earth
um and and that's a kind of a classic
example that actually the perceptive
experience of of how we experience the
sun is is not something that just gets
to like vanish out of out of thin air
simply because we kind of mathematically
prove that it's quote unquote
objectively untrue so that's I think the
thing I I love most about what Johnson
does
um thanks for sharing gents and um it's
also if we look at your book even in
Broad Strokes then and how to save the
West to answer you present five major
crises threatening to end Western
culture can you tell us what they are
and then we can see how they align with
some of the big challenges that Jonathan
sees
oh sure uh well I mean the the premise
of the book is basically you know I I
think people wake up the the people that
I talk to who listen to my podcast or or
what have you I I sense from them a real
sense of uh Despair and anxiety about
just where the world is headed about the
news cycle which seems to just
constantly deliver uh you know crisis
after crisis and the way that people
typically think about this is you know
how can I fix things and they they think
about it as if they were like Ron
DeSantis you know they they sort of uh
imagine like what law am I going to
write tomorrow what system am I going to
build uh Across the Nation that will uh
quote unquote you know fix the world or
save the west and I think that's what
causes that despair I think when people
think that way they start to paralysis
starts to set in because most of us
aren't Rhonda census and most of us have
been trained to think in these sweeping
political terms
um when what we really need is some
agents see over our own immediate
surroundings and personal you might even
say subjective lives and so the the
project of the book overall is to take
some of these things that are kind of
flitting past the news cycle
um and you know invite people into
speculation about what deeper questions
might be underlying them that are
answerable in human terms at an
individual human level
um and so the first one I call the
crisis of reality and that's related to
what we were just talking about it's
this you know is anything out there real
and if so what and uh do I want it to be
is it convenient to me for there to be
uh objective reality or even subjective
reality or would I rather kind of uh
dissolve the boundaries of true and
false in in some sort of digital space
um and then you know from closely
related to this is the crisis of the
body I think is is this um uncomfortable
relationship that we've had basically
for as long as we've been around on the
planet with our fleshly selves uh what
what does the soul have to do with flesh
why do we need this kind of appendage or
uh meat sack that just decays and dies
um and wouldn't it be better if we could
you know either manipulate it rearrange
it at will or
um maybe just Escape it all together in
some sort of you know code space
um and and so I kind of present as an
antidote to to that crisis the arguments
of Aquinas and you know drawing also on
Aristotle
um for for a hylomorphic world for a
world that is uh comprised of the fusion
of form and and matter threaded through
uh you know at every point with order
um that is more than than simply meat
um and this is kind of what leads into
the second uh half of the book with the
crisis of meaning and the crisis of
religion and that's where you start to
get into you know whether or not we can
believe in the wake of the Scientific
Revolution and the discovery of
evolution you know whether we can
um be confident in the things that we
perceive in this world that have no
place on a brain scan and yet we feel
very powerfully to be true
um then finally at last kind of having
addressed some of those what I'd
consider deeper philosophical issues
turn to the crisis of the regime which
is the you know the political issues
facing America and kind of drawing on
some of the history of political
philosophy to
um you know describe how regimes have
been understood to rise and fall so that
we can understand kind of what the
threats what the particularly acute
threats are uh to to ours in America and
and where we might be headed
um wonderful thanks Spencer would you
like to go with any of those in
particular and start off with Jonathan I
mean I think there's many there are many
things there that are interesting to me
um for sure the question of how we can
believe or you know how or why we should
believe in the the kind of scientific or
post-scientific World
um that is definitely one of the main
projects that I'm trying to to attend to
um and so I I'm definitely interested in
the notion that
cognitive science has afforded us a new
space to talk about these things that is
the inevitability of patterning and the
inevitability of of
um you know framing in terms of how we
see reality and how if you take that
seriously then in some ways it can
recapture our the phenomenological World
it can kind of recapture it as primary
it has to do with what you said in terms
of the sun coming up in the morning
right it's like if you if you can
realize that that
like the inevitability of of this
experience right of this conscious
experience and how how it's related to
meaning in general and how we make
meaning then it seems like almost all
the categories that you find in ancient
world like in scripture or in the
medieval world can be recaptured you
know I often give the example of going
up a mountain it's like going up a
mountain is an objective thing it's a
subjective thing but like in the way
that you said subjective but it has a
stable pattern to it and you can
recognize it and you can understand why
Moses goes up a mountain to encounter
God it's not it's something that you can
actually comprehend and have a little
experience of yourself
yeah you know this is related to
something I'd love for us to get into
that you were actually touching on
before we started recording
um and that is the kind of fractaline
nature of this stuff the way in which uh
you know reality Human Experience seems
to kind of consist in you know larger
patterns that can be infinitely sort of
nested within themselves one after the
other
um and I I think this is something I I
sort of address in the book I I think
this is one of the kind of dominant
patterns of ancient Greek philosophical
thought which is is has been lost to us
and and needs recovering you see it
maybe most clearly in in Plato's
Republic this notion that the city is a
kind of Soul mapped over many many
people and therefore the soul is a kind
of City nested within a single
individually and in both cases order is
the kind of spirit shared uh among these
two things man is as the microcosm is
the kind of class tagline for for
talking about this and I wonder you're
mentioning cognitive science I wonder if
that Concept in particular this idea
that you know the logos which is either
threaded through creation or expressed
in creation however you want to put it
um finds a kind of little mini uh
reiteration in the human mind
oh I think so I think that the fractal
to me the fractal structure that's the
that's the solution at least to help
people see what's going on and one of
the things I think we have access to
um right now that in some ways it's hard
to know to what extent the Ancients had
had access to it I think they did but
they would you know the idea of
microcosmic macrocosm for example you
find that of course like you said in the
in the Greek thinkers in in Plato and
then it it winds itself into
Christianity and finds its place and say
maximus and and in the more Cosmic
looking uh Christian uh thinkers but
there's a sense in which that microcosm
macrocosm is actually indefinite in
number so it's not that it's not that
there's like one microcosm and then the
macrocosm it's that there's levels and
if you read say maximus you kind of see
it it's like the individual is the
church is the cosmos and so it's like
the individual of the city is the cosmos
there's this there are these different
ways you can you can frame it but you
can go individual Church Cosmos you can
go individual Family Church Nation like
you can there are all these ways in
which these nested uh relationships work
and then you can go down from the
individual actually into the manner in
which your parts fit into you right and
that there's a kind of an indefinite way
in which anything that has multiplicity
uh joins into unity and so this is like
a stable pattern and it ended it's like
the one of the many basically is nothing
new we're not making anything up but uh
but that that understanding that it
nests itself all the way through is
really I think it's a solution to so
many of the of the problems that we have
because even in terms of politics we
tend I always see modernity as a
splitting of Heaven and Earth that's the
way that I understand it and it accounts
for more of modernity than some people
sometimes because people see in
modernity you know the Leviathan right
and then you you also see you know the
kind of noble savage idea but those are
the two things happening simultaneously
so it's like one is calling the other so
the idea that heaven and Earth are
separating
um and that that is reducing the fractal
relationships so you end up with
something like you know whatever
globalist World Government whatever like
obviously this is a little caricatured
and then
idiosyncratic you know I make up my own
identity whatever that is like I can be
a cat man or whatever at the bottom
right so it's like these two extremes
happening and the fractal is the way to
connect them together
um fascinating it's an intriguing
actually to think that you know in the
Scientific Revolution you have
notionally you have this connection
between the the sub-lunary and the super
lunary spheres that there was supposed
to be this division you know at the
orbit of the moon
um but in in point of fact what you're
saying is that in some ways the whole of
physical uh creation physical existence
was kind of brought down to the level of
the sub-lunaries and split off cut off
from from its its Heavenly sort of
vertical Dimension which is which is
really cool uh a cool way of thinking
about it I also think that this you know
is a is a mode of scriptural
interpretation that uh can be very
fertile and and fruitful when you're
trying to think about these questions
like can we believe how can we believe
how should we relate to these texts
which have been so kind of maligned and
dismissed as like Stone Age Superstition
or what have you but the other night I
was having a a conversation about you
know is the when God says to the nation
of Israel you know I know the plans I
have for you plans of good and not of
evil plans to prosper you
um is he just saying it to the nation of
Israel about the Exile in Babylon and is
the effort to kind of extract this verse
as people often do out of context and is
that effort just fundamentally misguided
and kind of the feature of American
Christian happy talk and one of the
things that I was drawing on in that
conversation is this notion which I
think I got from Aquinas although I I'm
not totally sure if I'm right about that
but you know this this notion that it's
somewhere in between those two things
right this is not just a kind of
floating set of words that you can apply
to any situation anywhere but neither is
it limited in its time at space context
or else none of scripture would really
have any meaning for us at all there's
got to be some kind of analogical link
that you can draw between the historical
experiences of the Jewish nation in
relationship to God and whatever it is
that's going on around us at a cosmic
level and I think this is this kind of
infinite nesting that you're suggesting
is is the link it's really important
what you say that like there's no
there's no ceiling to this it's not like
microcosm absolutely uh or like there's
you know just two options but rather
this is a kind of infinite chain and so
you could say well Israel in its kind of
nationhood represents or stands in four
but that's that's even not quite right
in some ways embodies
um you know a a cosmic man just as Adam
also can be conceived of as Cosmic man
and Christ of course as well and and you
know once you kind of get into this
um there's a million different ways that
you can legitimately and meaningfully
kind of draw uh significance out of
these historical events without just
kind of reducing them to like platitudes
or or
you're so right I mean it's all right
and I think it's that is bound in the
script the scripture itself you know
it's bound in the way the scripture
relates these together so if you think
about what you said in terms of the
nation of Israel the Covenant that God
makes with the nation of Israel and you
think of that already in the Covenant
itself there's a there's a fractal
relationship that gets set up which is
increasing so God makes this deal with
Moses and then Moses says like I can't
do it alone whatever and God sets up
mediations between Moses and the people
so you have God then you have Moses then
you have these mediations and then it
says Israel will be a Priestly Nation
what does that mean like priests for the
rest of the world that's what it means
and so the role that Moses is playing to
Israel is the role that Israel is
supposed to play to the world and that
is that is uh set up in the text itself
and if you see then from Exodus and you
kind of move on into the the story of of
the Bible you come to a point where this
seems to be increasing and increasing to
the point where God saying you know I I
will spit I will fill the entire Earth
with my spirit right it's like we will
as if you know when he when the promise
was made to to Abraham to make The
Descendants as numerous as the Stars you
get a sense even in the Old Testament
that this is going to be more than than
just the strict nation of Israel and
we're moving towards a time where God's
spirit will pour out unto all flesh so
if you see that as this fractal nesting
where it's like these these increasing
circles uh it's like I think it's right
there in the text and so it's not a I
don't think we're
I don't think we're just trying to
interpret something that that that that
we want to be there if we I think it's
there in the order of Revelation itself
it's remarkable I mean of course the
prophets maybe wrestle with this most
fruitfully in the you know lead up to
the Exile and then in in the uh
restoration this is you know the sort of
building of the second temple
um I I sort of discern it's it's not so
much a disagreement as just a kind of
mystery or a a you know a kind of
waiting about that very question like
when the Nations come to Zion like what
will that look like how can we sing the
Lord's song In a Strange Land and and
how is it possible for other cultures
with distinctive kind of practices and
this whole separate symbolic language
perhaps mutually unintelligible to the
you know to the Jewish Nation right you
know it's higher and Basin and just all
these other I mean Nations that haven't
even been known or named yet will come
to Zion and and you have this image I I
suppose you know in Isaiah 60 for
instance of like Zion is this kind of
ineffable core right kind of meaning
Beyond language Beyond symbolic
expression that joins together all of
these nations which you know sort of
horizontally amongst themselves have
nothing in common and are mutually
unintelligible or even adversarial in
the case of you know Babylon Syria
um and and this you know this kind of
symbolic or analogical relationship that
they're able to to develop is kind of I
think the glimpse of that uh in in in
the prophetic Visions let me ask you a
question that may well be above our pay
grade as human beings and therefore
unanswerable just to make it as easy on
you yeah it's just why not all right
yeah yeah I mean since here we are uh
and uh that is it seems to me that
um this kind of nested structure this uh
representative symbolic structure is
inherent in the Trinity itself in other
words it's not simply something that has
to do with the way that God must Express
himself to man and among Humanity
because of our distance from him or
because of our you know embodiment in in
matter
um but that actually it comes along even
in a pre-lapsarian way
um bound up with our nature as as images
of of God that we are three in one
already kind of within an individual
there's symbolic language going on Even
in our thought private thoughts to
ourselves Aristotle says you know no
thought is an image but no thought takes
place without images without pictures
Fantasia either
um and and I wonder whether
um trinitarian theology I mean you would
know a lot more about the patristic
literature on this than than I would
um you know whether it's a kind of an
article of trinitarian faith that
something about this symbolic uh gesture
is inherent in in God's nature of itself
I mean obviously I don't want to misstep
I always hate talk about Unitarian
theology unless someone calls me a
heretic you know and I don't even know
why uh but I I think that definitely the
one I think the moon of the Mysteries of
the revelation of the Trinity is the the
notion that Multiplicity
is in the godhead right that that in God
is both perfect unity and perfect
multiplicity and in some ways it's it
has to be represented as an aporia uh
because obviously we can't make sense of
it but but it's not a pooria that is
that is just arbitrary or illogical
because we can see in that aporia of of
of
proposing perfect unity and perfect
multiplicity that we see that happen at
lower and more imperfect levels in the
world so in the world we notice the
coexistence of unity and multiplicity
and we can see when that is balanced
like when there's we could say when
there's love and love is holding
multiplicity in unity and we can see
that so I think that I think that we are
meant
foreign
to live as an image of the Trinity uh
for sure and I think that and I thought
that's why I really do believe that
the trade I mean I'm preaching for my
for my own Parish or whatever but I do
believe that the trinitarian Revelation
in some ways is met even metaphysically
it's like the deepest
it's the deepest way to talk about the
infinite that that I can think of
because the problem with with the kind
of monadic vision right of the one and
that that type of language uh and I mean
I don't want to reduce the new plateness
but you know it's it can be done because
it tends to diminish it tends to
diminish multiplicity as being
derivative and as being uh you know
almost fallen in itself that kind of
Gnostic move that we saw at the in the
beginning of Christianity but
trinitarianism really puts multiplicity
as being in the very infinite itself
that's it's astounding to me like it's a
it's a beautiful image
um and to return to Dante you know I
think of his beatific Vision when he
finally makes it and as you say it's
it's apparetic in in some sense he loses
his power of speech as he frequently
does in the presence of the Divine and
yet it's quite a definite
um and and really quite strange image I
mean I've always thought that you know
his his image of the godhead is one that
you could you could never dream up sort
of on your own you know it feels very
right and yet he comes out with it and
you're sort of like that's quite
surprising and and you know it is
significant it seems that you know as
we've been talking about symbolism about
the sort of fractal nesting and and all
of that
um we almost can't escape some form of
hierarchic language right and you know
we make all these caveats we say you
know and yet you always get the kind of
bigger within the smaller or the and and
the thing that binds them is the form
um what Dante gives us is these three
Circles of distinct linked colors and so
of course the circle is you know a kind
of perfection of form he's able to
distinguish between these entities while
also you know affording to them a Kind
of Perfect synonymity or a perfect you
know identity with with one another
um and I I will be loose with my
language and ask for the Forgiveness of
the audience to you know when it comes
to heresy but that seems to me that what
Dante is is getting at that there is a
you know that although
in this world and you know because
creation creation being what it is
creating things that are other than God
right you know there's always going to
be a kind of graded uh variation of of
hierarchy within creation and that's
nothing evil or wrong about that
um but we also see as you said in on
kind of levels where uh all are equal
you can nevertheless have a kind of
Multiplicity
um in in Union that that Imogen at the
end of Dante I think kind of uh tries to
capture what that would be at its
highest in the godhead
yeah I mean I I agree and I think that
in terms of the Trinity it's interesting
to see I mean it's obviously different
fathers and different they're different
strains of how they talk about it how
they represented but there seems to be
on the one hand you can kind of feel
this tension right to not represent the
relationships as hierarchical right so
it's like no it's a heart some you hear
things like it's a hierarchy of function
but it's not a hierarchy of nature like
there's different ways to talk about it
but I think it's like they're trying
it's it's again it's a naporia there's a
naporia in the sense that there's a kind
of Distinction of function which appears
in some ways as a as a hierarchy but
because it's put into the infinite that
hierarchy
also dissolves at the same time into you
know into the infinite I don't know what
how else to say it and so and so it
gives us a model in some ways it becomes
a kind of infinite model of how we again
notice the the way that things work so a
really beautiful image of that I think
is for example when Christ you know so
so like Christ says you know I call you
my friends it's it's a beautiful image
because
the the disciples are not the one
calling Christ his friends right it's
like it's not the disciples saying hey
Buddy Jesus he's my buddy like they're
not the ones doing that Christ is the
one saying that so it's as if there's a
there's an acknowledgment of some of a
hierarchy
but then that hierarchy is is almost
reduced in Christ calling the disciples
to participate fully in him and so it's
like this it's really powerful to think
that it both both tells us like Christ
is above them and he so when he even
when he watches their feet it's like
there's a reason why they're shocked is
because right this is this is actually
this kind of cannotic uh movement that's
happening from Above Down Below so it
actually reinstates the hierarchy even
when he's watching his feet I'm sorry
Christians he's he's washing their feet
and they're all shocked and so it's both
him like losing himself in in that lower
part but then also reinstating it
inevitably just by the fact that he's
doing it so it's like that type of move
or the types of moves that Christ does
to to at least give us a hint of how
this kind of equal equality and
hierarchy can can exist in it how it
seems to exist infinitely in God somehow
I don't know how to phrase it
but well it threads right through so
many of his sayings not just that moment
which you're right is I I've never quite
thought of it that way it's a very
beautiful a beautiful beautiful in its
Simplicity almost but also you know he
who would be first must be last right is
kind of the the little nomic version of
of what you're saying and and also the
parable where the you know the keeper of
the feast says friend go go up higher
you know it's not that like if you put
yourself there somehow you've you've
destroyed the entire dance and yet if
you you know offer yourself in humility
then you've created the opportunity for
that for that philia to be kind of
offered there's there's a um a little
tossed off comment somewhere in CS Lewis
I'm going to forget where he's he says
it but he mentions that condescension is
this beautiful word that we have spoiled
and there's it's a beautiful idea I mean
that when I descendo when I go down con
with you
um or you condescend to me
um our or sort of you know maybe it has
to do with what Alexis de tocqueville
says about Americans that there's a kind
of the Mania for uh equality in us that
it can kind of be let loose and we have
this egalitarian kind of um wrangling
that I'm as good as you and nobody is
born you know at the natural master of
any other and all these things of course
you know are true in in a certain sense
um and yet as as you say we recognize
everywhere around us that there are
people with you know greater gifts than
us people with other gifts from us or in
positions where they for one reason or
another you know their Grace consists
precisely in
um you know lifting us up out of a lower
position which you can't celebrate or be
grateful for or acknowledge if you
insist that you were already in the
higher position on the same plane with
the person to begin with so this I mean
even the way that we use that word
condescension as if it were some sort of
inherently snide or sneering action when
in fact it's the whole basis almost of
of Love or at least a certain kind of
love
I I think I think you've got it right
and it's
in some ways the because I've talked
about I've been talking about hiking for
years right and and a lot of people and
even because I'm talking about hierarchy
sometimes in the wake of Jordan Peterson
uh and so Jordan at first was always
talking about dominance hierarchies if
you remember he doesn't say that anymore
by the way but he used to be a part of
your influence yeah I don't know but
it's like in a ways thank goodness for
that but uh I think that real that is
one of the Mysteries that Christianity
seems to offer which is that
Christianity I think is hierarchical but
it's properly hierarchical it's like
canonic canotically hierarchical which
is the idea that we do recognize those
that rise up let's say and that become
heads Kings you know princes and
different in different spheres of
reality but that we know like what so
the way it's supposed to be at least in
the Christian image is that those that
rise up give themselves back to those
that are below and so the the the notion
of like the servant leader it's a bit of
a cliche but it I think it has a a very
deep structural purpose which is to
preserve the the the importance of
hierarchy and the inevitability of
hierarchy but understand that the proper
mode of hierarchy is love right the one
that is above loves those that are that
are in his body right you know the king
loves the loves the people the the
husband loves the family loves his wife
and so that that that's the type of
imagery that's given yeah and I think
that I don't see a better solution to
the problem of hierarchy than that one
yes you know this year I have
encountered for the first time and maybe
I should be embarrassed that it's the
first time that I've encountered Thomas
trahern
um and I guess by this year I mean last
year 2022.
um and and this you know kind of uh
Mystic uh Vision in his centuries of
meditations uh that by truly seeing
another uh person or indeed by seeing
creation we we possess it we have it in
the way that God has all things and this
is you know ultimately his his gift for
us he
foreignt given you the entire world
um and and you sort of think well
actually no I'm just a schmuck with like
you know a house in in Nashville and he
says no no by present by giving you eyes
he's given you the entire world
essentially by giving you a
Consciousness that's capable of
delighting in uh other things besides
yourself God has given you a gift that's
fit basically the only otherwise for him
and for the angels and I I found this
very Illuminating when I went back to a
passage in Paul which is sort of cited
so often that it's it's very easy to
overlook as just a kind of one of those
platitudes you know and that is the
passage about the body of Christ and you
know shall the eye say to the hand
because I am uh not a hand I am not part
of the body and so forth you know I
think I've heard a lot of sermons about
that passage that go something like you
know everybody has different gifts and
isn't that nice you know that we can all
do different things in the church and I
you know of course that's true and
probably a part of what Paul was saying
and yet it's it's much more profound
than that you know to be to be a member
of a body with uh other people and to
learn to Delight in them the way that
you might Delight in a sunset right you
know that um and in some ways think of
you know the the talents and Gifts of
others as given to you because you know
the moment you're able to take the
Delight in them rather than you know
Envy them or be jealous of them um
suddenly they do in in some sense belong
to you through that philia through that
love
um and and it's you know it's achingly
beautiful except of course that like
it's so hard to do you know that doesn't
stop you from then going away and sort
of being jealous of people and having
that you know Broken Man within but
still it's a it's a lovely idea
um and so what what what I'm curious a
little bit about Marcus have you read
did you have a chance to read the book
yet do you have read yeah let's go I'd
like to hear a little bit based on what
we're saying what your what Your
perception is in terms of of the some of
the the solutions or ideas that Spencer
brings about hmm
so I think one of the things that really
struck me with Spencer was and it
started on young Heritage and it's kind
of been rearrated in the book but
that's true like I your dad who actually
says Spencer is that trinitarian
structure as a Kenny foundation and how
that works out it kind of fractal they
kind of can a fractal manner it's that
stuck with me and one area I was kind of
interested in exploring was how they
supplies something you talk about is it
how evolution is biological and cultural
and it's endless kind of like you said
there's no sailing and it seems to be
this plays out with Evolution too but
how in line with that fractal pattern
structure do we come to the kind of
original model in this kind of mimetic
way and they how does that contrast with
the kind of dominant um
can a philosophical Darwinism that's
materialist and structure doesn't have
that figure to actually mimic as a kind
of a good and enough that makes sense
yeah yeah this is something that I I
think first struck me with uh you know
when I was when I was reading Renee
Gerard of course the you know the great
uh Expositor of of my mesis of a certain
kind and it does seem to me that you're
talking earlier Jonathan about dominance
hierarchies you know if if indeed our
imitation our symbolic language our
mimesis doesn't have some Bedrock have
some final model of or frame of
reference
um then it really is just dominance all
the way down you know it then in fact
all the reductive things that we were
saying aren't true you know that like
the there's no ceiling to reality where
you know and there's no kind of like uh
just pure relation of of dominance and
submission
um if if you genuinely believe is for
instance Richard Dawkins does it like
it's it's just replication kind of all
the way down
um then then the world is basically
reduced to a kind of of power play
um one of the things I think I say in
the book is you know if different texts
from Antiquity carry different way to
different times which seems sort of
obvious except that we have this notion
of the Canon right as consisting of
certain books and and no others or books
having different kind of weight within
the hierarchy
um and I think you know Jonathan when we
met and talked you recovered for me a
sense of the urgency for instance of
patristic literature right that this is
something that you kind of don't get in
a like Humanities Western Civ course
most of the time and yet uh you know is
particularly urgent for all sorts of
reasons that we've sort of been Adam
braiding it's particularly urgent now
um another text that I present in the
book as as being sort of newly or
freshly urgent is Plato's Timaeus
um and you know contrasting uh what a
Humanities education would have looked
like in the in a medieval University
with what a Humanities education in
America for the last 100 years has
looked like right if an under graduate
reads any Plato today in college he
probably reads the Republic
and probably the Timaeus is like a
footnote or something
um but of course it's Timaeus is the
literary sequel to The Republic in some
sense it it transcends the Republic by
asking questions that you know predate
or go deeper than it
um and it it contains I think one of the
fullest expressions in a pagan context
of the kind of relationships that we've
been that I think are most fully
revealed But ultimately in in the
Christian context
um and I think that you know Harry Jaffa
has this wonderful line that
um the West is is saved or revitalized
every time a human heart is saved from
The Dark Knight of nihilism and
relativism
um and this is kind of the premise also
of of of my book that you know you've
titled a book how to say the west and of
course you feel a certain trepidation
about like if people are going to look
to you for some political program or
some you know list of answers
um but the point that I'm I'm trying to
make in in the book which Marcus I think
you you get at really well is like you
know actually the you know the the
restitution the restoration of of every
human heart is the project of of the
West and I think the first step to that
because very close to everything we've
been talking about the first step to
that has to be
um some recovery of this of the validity
of symbols right of of the uh just the
the fact that these are not kind of
arbitrary or accidental features of our
biology but are I think you use the word
primary Jonathan that they are in some
sense kind of a Bedrock uh of of reality
and and you know this is I think
expressed very well in in the Timaeus
and kind of carried forth
um by by these Christian Traditions
you've been talking about
I think I think you're right I think it
is even an interesting way to bind this
back to Marcus's like uh comments about
the question of of evolution let's say
so this is only a Jordan has been
bringing up more and more and and some
people can see it some people don't
don't perceive what he's trying to to
say which is that that there's a
difference between
replication and variation and selection
selection is not the same and and with
Jordan without using platonic language
or using uh Christian language is trying
to point to is that that selection
implies a good there's no other way
around that that all selection implies
are good
and so the question is well if all
selection no matter what level you see
it from the the most basic uh you know
level of of biology to you know who you
decide is the president like from all
all these levels uh yeah necessitate at
least the notion of the good and so it's
as if Darwin without knowing it
is bringing back like a kind of
metaphysics of quality uh that that then
re-inscribes itself right into the
system even from the bottom up somehow
and that is why I think the idea for
example that that's why I think you'd be
talking about Jordan again like why
Jordan has now moved away from talking
about dominance hierarchies to talk
about risk reciprocity and hierarchy and
how he says it's actually more accurate
to say that there's always a kind of
reciprocity that that manifests itself
in in hierarchies and that let's say
that reciprocity is
is less apparent maybe in lower levels
of life but that as it kind of moves up
uh towards Consciousness then becomes
more and more apparent uh you know he
talks about chims all the time and stuff
but that but that this sense in which if
we understand these Goods then
as we can perceive them right we can see
the goods and we can see how they're
embedded together and the question is
how do they scale up more and more and
then we're like from Darwin straight
back into Dante like just jump from one
to the other and we we ultimately now
entered into the ascent of purgatory
moving up into the virtues and into the
notion of of being itself and it's like
I think that that's such it's such a
crazy time and it's hard to formulate it
for people but I think we're we're
getting there like we're kind of we're
kind of tossing out ways to formulate it
so people can see the strange flip and
the flip that's happening is really
similar to the Dante flip it's like
materialism brought us right away all
the way to the bottom right all the way
to the bottom where we thought we'd
reduce everything to Mechanical
causation to to just these chemicals
that interact with each other and then
right on the flank of the of the devil
we find the world turning up turning
back and then we find ourselves going
back up into a world of selection and
quality that leads us you know all the
way up the mountain so it's a it's such
a weird and fascinating time to to be
able to talk about these things
wow yeah it's uh that's just beautifully
put and it is very difficult to get
people to see I I think that because one
of the rhetorical
moves I think that we performed to get
us down to that kind of pure Clockwork
that Mechanical Universe was to adopt
all sorts of language that implies
action but no actor
and you see this with the replacement of
you know Notions like form and spirit
right that you replace those Notions
with words like impetus Force momentum
right
um and these words because of the way I
think language sort of calcifies over
time you know they they have these dead
metaphors inside of them that enable us
to trick ourselves into thinking about
action and and spirit without will or
intention and when you when you really
ask people to say well what's behind
that language right what is a force
what's energy right
um
they either can't do it or they don't
even know what you're asking right these
are kind of primary categories they just
it just is like I it's like a crackling
blue force that moves through the the my
picture of the world you know and and
this is everywhere in the in the
scientific language I mean it's mostly
it has a lot to do just as a sort of
nerdy linguistic note I think it has a
lot to do with the transition from Greek
to Latin that Latin as it becomes this
kind of erudite language and Associated
really with the kind of you know the
university
um has this kind of clinical tone to it
this feeling we can trick ourselves into
using it as if there were kind of no
consciousness behind any of this action
but as as you're saying of course you
know the more you chase that down to its
nub the the more the action kind of
comes in the back door the Consciousness
comes in the back door this is what
happens what's happening to physics
right now you know like as we speak the
the physicists are dealing with this
problem
um and and there is I think you know
just the simple observation that right
think about like the invention of the
word meme right Dawkins writes the
selfish Gene he proposes this idea that
you know they're not just actually uh
physical structures that uh are better
or worse at replicating themselves and
surviving it's also cultural uh patterns
and and practices and modes of behavior
and as you say you know there's a smug
there's a concept of value smuggled in
there there's always a concept of of the
good right
um and it just so happens that if you
want to exclude
will and Consciousness from your picture
of the world than the only concept of
the good available to you is is survival
is brute strength or some form of
longevity or smarts or cunning or
whatever
um and people can't can't live that way
so there is kind of this I think uh as
you say there is this turn now to
recognize that if every action implies
some some good if there's a standard
sort of involved in everything
um then there must in fact be some actor
behind all these uh action-laden words
that that we're using yeah and even if
you can if you can see the fractal
running all the way through right if you
can see the fractal running all the way
through then all of a sudden the let's
say survivability even survivability so
think about it in terms of metaphysics I
always kind of want to use meta physical
words to talk about this it's like what
is what is evolution it is it is it is
the tendency of being to persist right
it's the tendency of being to be that's
that's what evolution is and so if you
can nest if you can Nest that together
so you think it's like survival I I have
to care let's say about my survival but
in order for that survival to be at its
highest good I also have to have a
certain amount of care for those that
are subjugated to me because they are in
some ways that which make me survive but
then I also have to participate
adequately in whatever higher structure
I'm participating in right so it's like
whatever higher structures I'm
participating in I have to so if I just
become parasitic and I just want what's
mine where I am that will not that will
in the end like I say at the bigger
scale it will not Foster even my own
good right you know like we know that
because it happens in us right become
obsessed with something we just want to
have this one thing we think that's what
we need and then we what what happens is
that the system self destroys and that
happens at the level of the individual
if an individual just tries to survive
in a system without giving up to the
system so think about a policeman he
just tries to get as much as he can from
the system without feeding into the
higher participations he's in at some
point
it's gonna crumble and his own reality
is going to crumble so there's a sense
in which if you see this if you see this
even survival as being embedded all the
way up and up Beyond human beings then
again you're back in Dante and it's like
then the virtues matter then then then
the goods that you perceive as the
manner in which we come together love
honesty all these laws that we have are
actually
very easily defensible in terms of
understanding survivability at higher
levels of participation and so that's
what I mean like it's this joke like
it's almost like a joke to notice how if
you if you take all this very seriously
and you look at how everything embeds
you end up back into a metaphysical
Universe from the bottom up
I I have a question for uh both of you I
mean Marcus if you've got uh thoughts on
this jump please jump in I
you mentioned and I I really agree with
this you mentioned the sort of
difficulty of getting these ideas across
and I think we can talk about we have
been talking about sort of reasons why
that might be
um
I'm wondering about your state of of
optimism uh or or lack thereof regarding
that I mean because on the one hand it's
really easy to just sort of feel like
the kind of weight the inertia to use a
quasi sort of scientific term right the
inertia of this way of thinking is so
great that people can't even it's like
water they're swimming through or air
they're breathing
um and yet at the on the other hand
you are implying I think and I I feel
this too that like there's an inflection
point like going on right now you know
that there is this kind of uh turn about
to happen
um or or even in the process of
happening where people are kind of you
know hitting rock bottom and then going
through to the other side when when at
that moment when gravity Turns Upside
Down you know
um and and I wonder you know is that
just kind of something that people who
like us who get to talk about this stuff
we just have to kind of wait that out
and keep keep talking about it you know
or like what's the uh what's your
prognosis on that
um
well I I think that the best image is to
understand it is like the planted seed I
think in some ways it's the best way to
understand it right the seed is planted
in the decomposing
of the former world and so I think that
we so but while the seed is a seed and
while the seed is a is a Little Seedling
the world still looks and is still
mostly decompo like it's still mostly
decomposed and so I think that I so I
think that and or even if you understand
an image of the solstice for example
it's like nobody knows on the day of the
solstice that the days are getting
longer it's like you know if you know
the secret but it is going to take a few
weeks before you realize that that light
is returning and I think that that's
something that something uh like that
where we where we are is I think that on
the one hand things are going to get a
whole lot worse and things are gonna I'm
sorry to say I'm sorry to to yeah things
are gonna get a lot crazy get ready for
2024 people it's going to be an insane
year and there's no way around it okay
so so we know that it's going to get
worse but I do believe I do still have
hope because I do see the seed planted
and I do see the seedling kind of hidden
in the brush and so so so I and in some
ways life is there's a reality to life
that's undeniable right it's like I
think truth wins in the end and so I do
believe that whatever is real will
persist ultimately through the through
the madness so
yeah a uh a statistical projection model
on the day of the first solstice would
have predicted that states would just
get infinitely short until there was no
light left on the earth at all right
that's right that's right I'm curious
about Marcus what do you think I mean
because you're also putting so much
energy into all of this like what's your
what's your prognosis on on where we're
going and and yeah yeah be in the
interview I'll bring it back to a
question quite quickly let's say I'll
give a little bit about that so
obviously speaking with you gents online
and using the benefits of modern
technology there's so many ways that it
is so positive it's obviously marked for
that deep ambiguity that you're
referring to there so some of the good
friendships that I've developed over the
last few years have been true media like
this and now thank God I have been able
to take that with these events that were
planning for Dublin and things like that
into a embedded kind of proper
communities and then hopefully that will
plant those little seeds to go out into
the rest of Ireland around the world and
I've been blessed to have wonderful
events with Paul Kings a lot of people
came from Slovakia all these places I've
never been to Slovakia how would I meet
slovakians it wasn't for things like
this but um obviously one thing I
appreciate about your work Jonathan both
of you guys is that you do talk with
this dark side of technology and
I've always been struck indelibly by
Yvonne election how he describes the
kind of Corruption of Christianity so
the corruption of the best is the worst
you get all these wonderful gifts but
then subverted and then I suppose in
some ways you just find it to the the
opposite of that with these great crises
they're the greatest opportunities and
Dr Richard back he talks about that at
the kind of psychological level too but
um
I think
identifying the question I want I want
to ask you guys how you think we can not
only can it easily
um sustainable way get that virtual
reality that relationship with virtual
reality and Virtual Technology that we
can
supplement our real lives with the
staple that you're talking about and
that's another thing in Spanish book the
importance of the body the importance of
embodiment being the staple
how do we then get it if it might do
some knowledge of food how do we get it
use these Technologies as supplement so
they're not
um
subverting the kind of or Christian
witness yeah yeah yeah don't go too long
with that
that's a great I think to me like that's
a great question and I think you're
using the right words that you're using
the right words when you talk about
technology as supplementarity I think
that's the best way to understand it and
that's the way that we can understand it
where it will play the most positive
role that is technology is an extension
of embodiment that's what it is it's
it's like a it's an extent you know a
car is an extension of your body
everything that has that all the technes
is extension of power on the world right
that's what we have now the problem that
we're dealing with is really it's weird
because it's like it really is in some
ways a problem that is well described in
the Book of Revelation it's the problem
of of an image that speaks right that's
the problems the problem of like an
extension of you that speaks
and so what is what is going what's
happening what's going on so all of a
sudden it's as if the world of Techni
has been is trying to reach into the
world of intelligence and is trying to
it's kind of like trying to pry at the
door of of intelligence uh and we we
know all we know like just most of us
know that this is of is fascist that
this is it's like it's a it's a it's a
trick that's being played this is not
real but the effect of it on on most of
the population seems to be the opposite
of that it seems to be a a longing right
for the for technology to move into
intelligence and think for us you could
say or or tell us what to do uh and I
think that that's the that in some ways
we have a clear image of what the danger
is like we have a clear the clearance
that you can find and so the the only
way for technology to to be useful is
only if it acts as that extension and
like a extension that's far away and so
you you talked about that before market
so it's like my priority is my is my
spiritual life my family my community
and then that can reach out into the
extensions that technology affords me
but the hierarchy has to be in the right
order and I'm not saying that telling
you that I've succeeded in doing that
it's very difficult but I think that
that's that that's the that's the proper
hierarchy and if we have it in in that
proper hierarchy technology can actually
be a great Boon because it does extend
us like it really does like the message
that I'm saying I never could have been
speaking to so many people you know a
thousand years ago there's no way and so
it's like so it does have a great power
that we could that that can be used
properly if it's in the right place
foreign
there was this moment
uh last year
with this Google engineer his name was
Blake Lemoyne or Lemoine and I'm not
sure how you say it but he basically
convinced himself that the language
learning and replicating software he'd
been working on Lambda for Google their
their version of chat gbt basically like
this app for just AI generation of of
text
um he convinced himself that this
program was a lot
news program that he had helped to build
and he staged this long still available
online this long uh interview with
Lambda to prove that it had come to life
and it shouldn't be turned off because
it had a right to life and it involves
things like you know what do you think
of as your soul do you have a soul and
what's your soul like and yes I have
soul and would come back to him with all
of these things that it knew he wanted
to hear right because this is sort of
how this stuff works it takes in
patterns of speech and then it spits
them back out in new combinations very
clever ways
um and there was something very
sort of tragic and heartbreaking about
it because the the concept of the soul
that this program had was almost
identical it was like the perfect
version of like a Silicon Valley kind of
you know Guru like flirting with
Buddhism it's a Stargate it's like this
you know a very a radiating ball of
energy whatever
um and so it was just obviously a mirror
he's obviously looking in a mirror that
talks back at him and this moment I
cannot get this moment out of my head
because before that I think I had this
very silly idea that like there's two
kinds of idolatry there's the old-timey
kind of idolatry in the the Hebrew Bible
where you know Isaiah says a man cuts
down a tree he chops it in half he makes
half of it into a God he burns the other
half for firewood and then he bows down
before this this sculpture right that
you know his eyes but cannot see it has
uh ears but cannot hear and and the
worshipers become like they too their
eyes cannot see their ears counted and I
thought but then we got too smart for
that and we you know stopped falling for
that self-deception and instead now we
have the new kind of idolatry which is
like a sort of abstract ideology we will
idolize money we idolize the economy we
idolized security Comfort whatever
um
and watching this guy talk to this thing
which his own hands had made uh and
attributing to it Consciousness right
sort of imputing uh an independent life
that could tell him things that he
didn't know to it I was like oh no it's
all the old kind of idolatry there's
only one kind of idolatry and it just
because it persists right it's like the
human heart Factory vitals
um and this is a very long-winded way of
saying like I I think this point about
techne as you know that almost are the
the form that our mind applies to it is
as important as the form that it
actually has in in reality right the
conceiving of it as an extension of
ourselves
um has a very important corollary which
is that
if there's an extension of something
then that thing has a kind of Baseline
right there to even think of something
as an addition or an attribute or
something um is to propose implicitly
that there is some core to reality and
unless we recover this embodied sense of
the core of reality
um we'll never use technology properly
so it ironically like the the way in is
like daily practice of extremely basic
stuff rare right you know cooking for
people uh turning your phone off and and
like having an interaction with your
spouse these things are you know they
sound so simple they're so difficult to
do but the reason that they they matter
is like that mustard seed right I mean
you were talking about this I think like
one of the things about a seed is that
it has a particular kind of food or
nourishment that's proper to it that
wouldn't be proper to the fully grown
entity so you know if we are in this
stage of kind of embryonic like nascent
realization self-realization
um then it might not be the case that
like tomorrow we're gonna wake up in
Dante's Paradise like we have to you
have to go through those stages of
development first and we think that oh
we're beyond all this but actually you
know these very basic practices like
wake up in the morning you know get on
your knees and pray and then like make
yourself an actual physical like meal
that you eat like um these these things
are are so important precisely because
they root you in the proper kind of
starting point from which you can then
Branch out and and use technology I mean
that seems like the whole task ahead of
us in some ways
yeah that makes that makes sense that
makes so much sense and you see it like
if I always say there are two images of
technology in in the Book of Revelation
one is the Beast and the image of the
Beast and the system of the Beast you
know the naming and all that stuff and
then the other one is the Heavenly
Jerusalem and the Heavenly Jerusalem has
the order that you mention right at the
what's at the middle of the Heavenly
Jerusalem it's a tree and the Water of
Life the tree of life and the Water of
Life are at the at the center of the
Lamb is at the center and then you have
a wall on the outside right you have
Techni there on the outside but it is
it it it's on the outside it's not it's
not in the middle right and it has the
proper order related to what is the
priority and then what is what is
secondary so
I definitely agree with that
so I'm actually curious how this applies
to two particular types of media that
you have both kind of worked with so one
being movies for yourself I suppose
Jonathan and to video games for yourself
Spencer and your dad's recent video and
video games I thought was most
interesting to do very helpful for
understanding that you kind of described
it as a new high art in line with
painting and things in the past so I'm
wondering how so if I know from my
experience I've used some of your videos
teaching kids in school and that
Jonathan and they I the point of entry
was really true movies Logan
commentaries things like that and then
they could come to the mountain to see
the biblical patterns through that but
I'm conscious of what you just say it's
better about people's starting and this
kind of very secular secularized world
they're gonna make those things first
how do we then
um use those for ministry as it were and
and you have them like the walls outside
does that make sense
I think I mean so I mean I think that's
the way to understand it I don't have
like I don't have a problem with secular
cultural manifestations but I think it's
all about hierarchy you know it's
actually a hierarchy that is there in
the very form of those social those
cultural manifestations which is that
there's a difference between
entertainment and true participation
there's a difference of level of
participation between the type of
participation you have in the video game
and the type of participation you have
in your family and it's like if the
order can be preserved you know it's
like the difference between
participation in a game and
participation in liturgy you know
there's a hierarchy of participation
that exists but you know a game
definitely has a cosmic form and the the
video games so much so like video games
are are little microcosms they kind of
have to be because they're they have to
condense so many things into a into a
universe or a world that can be grasped
and so they can sometimes actually shine
very brightly because they they have to
like they have to condense everything
they have to have a clear hierarchy of
progression they have to have a clear
hierarchy of characteristics that you
will embody in order to advance and they
you know there has to there's all these
structures that have to be uh that have
to be put into the game for you to care
about it uh and so you can find quite
quite a bit in that and the same with
movies the difficulty that we have of
course is you know our world is upside
down and so we think that culture is
movies like we think that that's what
culture is like culture is
you know dance is not dancing dancing is
watching the ballet right and and and
and stories are it's not something that
you should engage in and participate in
but it's just something you should sit
down with the tub of popcorn and watch
so and there's nothing wrong with doing
that I think it's just about it's about
hierarchy
hmm
yeah you know this problem with video
games which uh you are sort of alluding
to Jonathan which is that people are
hypnotized by them you know because I
I'm a great lover of video games and
have defended their proper place in that
hierarchy you know and I'm kind of on
the hook for this you know so it's like
people come to me all the time with like
well my son plays six hours of video
games at a stretch right and I my usual
answer to this is like well you know
Plato would would like a word because
just because something is art doesn't
mean it's necessarily good for you and
it's not necessarily good for you in all
those those quantities right
um and and I think that this is
um
you know I went to this concert uh of
Final Fantasy music here at the
Nashville Symphony and it was really
beautifully done and they had these you
know thick and kind of played uh video
from the game as they as they played the
score and you know that is certainly a
little Universe a kind of imaginative
Universe which
um draws these very dreamlike
associations between things and and
um is clearly working out some sort of
idea precisely about the role of of
Technology the kind of threat that
technology poses to our imaginations to
um the kind of Heroes Quest you know
um and so it's obvious that something is
going on here that we would be sort of
foolish to deny
um and yet as we have known for a long
time or you know people who think about
this stuff no like art is radioactive
material you Handle With Care right and
it has a kind of seductive power uh as
precisely because of its uh importance
for us it's it's how to put it it's kind
of weapons grade emotion you know and
and um I I think that uh I love that
weapons great emotion that's awesome I
mean this is like I came this is the
term that I I was trying in grad school
to kind of Express like what Plato
thinks about music and I think that's
kind of it you know weapons great
emotion is like it's just straight into
your veins you know
um and
you know Augustine has this wonderful
comment in book 10 of the confessions
where he's reviewing his passions and
his appetites and obviously he's had
this tremendous struggle with his sexual
appetite which he's now kind of overcome
but that approach that he uses he has
this wonderful Insight that the approach
he used for his sexual appetite which
was effectively to quit Cold Turkey
um is actually not uh applicable to
every situation in which you might feel
desires or over indulge in things
um and the classic example of this is
food like there is a problem which is
that we eat too much because we like the
taste of food
um and Augustine puts this as like you
know the your your desires outstrip your
health the object what's objectively
good for you
um and yet God has made it so that we
can't just say well I'm just not gonna
eat right because you will die and and
so you're actually forced into a
relationship of Engagement and therefore
Mastery right you're if you're going to
survive in this world
um you can't simply renounce your
passions you actually have to affirm
them and gain Mastery over them and
understand that even though they seem
very powerful they their proper place is
actually beneath your reason is actually
in objection to the governing principle
the hegemonicon you know the thing in
you that uh you know is sort of most
closely connected to the Divine uh logos
and and I think that you know we're in
this position right now with a lot of
our tech and and with a lot of our art
video games are a great example it's
like you know you are
um being offered something that you
can't deny you can't it it's it's no
solution to just say well scrap this all
together ban it kick it out of the
Public's figure because it just is bad
for us um and yet it precisely because
it so obviously has Excellence uh it's
the kind of Excellence that it has is is
um something you need to Handle With
Care and learn to exercise self-control
over which is a daily a daily practice
but it's like there's there's really God
I think God has put us in a position
where there's no other way out basically
is what I'm trying to say
that's a good it's a and we're right
back in Dante you know again is it's
always about you know the way that Dante
frames all his his story is that it's
all about mishandling of goods things
that are not but nothing things are not
bad in themselves it's just about having
them in their their proper place and in
some ways it's like it's the role of
mediation to some extent to be always
dangerous like all mediations towards
the highest good are dangerous because
they're not the highest good but that's
also how the world works it's like
without without that there's no world
like the world is the mediation of goods
into multiplicity and so the the very
fact that multiplicity is there you know
is both as great opportunity to have
this ladder of goods that you can
participate in but it's always like you
said it's always a danger because you
can always mistake you know the the the
the step of the ladder for the final
place you're going so
um so I think that yeah but it's true
that we are in a position right now
where we're so assaulted it's it is more
difficult because you know we are
assaulted by very sophisticated
um you know very sophisticated
stimuli and and things that try to kind
of gather gain our attention from us
um so we we it's difficult but for sure
that's the battle that we have that's
our generation's battle is somebody's a
battle of attention like what what is
going to get our attention and how much
of it of it are we going to give to to
different things
um yeah it's um it is remarkable how
often it comes back to Dante and how
often just in general the Middle Ages
seem to have something for us that they
they maybe Haven't You Know spoken quite
so
urgently to to Generations before hours
but I mean this um I like that the the
battle for attention who was it you were
telling me uh when we hung out that uh
somebody says that Christ on the cross
creates the world yeah same accident
says that I'm sure other people say that
but same access definitely said that
Christ he was as he when he was on the
cross he was creating the world which is
yeah yeah well it's I mean there's this
problem in so many ways but I think it's
profound for this reason as well which
is that as you're saying right like the
the very creation of a POS the
possibility to choose good creates this
negative space right creates this void
and like there's no living life without
you know touching or exposing yourself
to the possibility of overindulgence
because the things the very things that
are good for you are capable of being
overindulged and I think like the to
understand
Creation The Very notion that God would
ever create something other than himself
kind of implies that out of love right
out of his sheer just Superfluous desire
for you to be around if I can put it
this way like he's going to create
something other than himself so that you
can choose him and it's like the the
crucifixion the the agony of the Cross
is bound up in that first moment in the
you know the very choice to to create it
all hmm
yeah that's definitely that's definitely
and it and it does in some ways and
again it solves the same problem it
solves the problem of hierarchy like the
cross just solves like what do we lift
up right and it says you know we lifted
up it's like lifting up and it's a man
being tortured and crucified that's
what's being lifted up so it kind of
brings it into an into the saporia
um of what hierarchy means in the
Christian sense uh yeah for sure the
crosses
it's hard to talk about that the cross
it just just destroys you every time you
start to talk about it yeah
yeah
um well I mean the analogy with the
serpent in the desert if that's if an
algae is the the word I want right like
yeah the um I I think I mentioned this
to you at some point this
um the discovery that hit me the first
time I read the gospels in Greek
um which is always when people say like
why do you learn Asian languages what's
the point of any of it why why would you
like aren't there good translations
um I realized when I read the gospels in
Greek that I I had never understood the
Christian concept of forgiveness
um because Greek has two words for
forgiveness one of which uh is is quite
common at least in classical Antiquity
and that's like the the knowledge
alongside somebody I understand why you
did this
um but the gospels so far as I know
never used that word which would have
been very normal and natural to use for
cassid or for forgiveness or whatever
the you know Hebrew concept is that
they're translating and uh instead they
use this word AFI Ami and a Festus is
the noun and that's uh Apple away and
hear me I Cast Away right I throw away
and when you when you actually forgive
somebody you might not understand why
they did anything at all right you you
in fact you you cast it away you make it
of no account
um and this is also the word that I
think Luke uses for giving up the spirit
on the cross when he gave up his his
ghost he afiyami um and so that act of
forgiveness which is the same as the act
of separating your very soul from your
body in some sense or yourself from
yourself
um yeah that you're right this is like a
talking about this just kind of
dissolves one into a blubbering Heap
but it is very uh yeah it's the answer
to everything and so what so I'm curious
about so what do you like what's your
what are your hopes for the for the book
like what what do you what do you hope
to Foster
oh well thank you for for asking that um
you know I first and foremost uh I I
hope that people can gain a sense of
ownership over the uh classical
tradition over the the text of the of
the Canon
um but also over their
um their intuitions of that which is
more than you know mirror matter that
which is is immeasurable but real
um and and that's kind of the extended
argument of the book that's how I
concluded is that you know we've been
talked out of our intuitions we've been
talked out of our I mean the kind of
Internet version of this is like what's
your source for that right what's your
source for being in love with that
person what's your source for uh you
know the beauty of that Sunset
um and so there's kind of two forms of
ownership that I think I'm I'm trying to
uh afford to people or at least to give
people permission to to have ownership
of their um of their intuitions of their
of their subjective experience of the
world uh understood as we've been
discussing it here
um but also over the uh textural
Traditions that come down to us that can
kind of Shepherd us through this in in
in a much richer and more humane way
than I think a lot of our current kind
of gurus and ideologues can can offer I
you know the experience of young
Heretics really drove this home to me
even though I probably would have before
I did the podcast I probably would have
said like oh yeah the classics are for
everybody you know you can Aristotle is
just a book about how to be good at
being human you know
um and I I think that I said that but it
was only when people started reaching
out to me and saying like I'm on my
tractor and I'm thinking about the Nicki
McKean ethics because you told me to
like that's kind of that's that's the
end goal here that's what I I you know I
I think that people have been scared
away from this for all sorts of reasons
political reasons intellectual reasons
uh reasons of power and money
um and and the hope for for the book is
that it will give people a little bit of
of ownership over those traditions
that's great it's a great it's a great
uh let's say
yeah it's a great project thanks thanks
for being along the uh along with me on
this this this desire let's say oh well
thank you I it's a pleasure and an
inspiration to to talk to you as usual
and by the way there's some people who
are watching Spencer and I are going to
be on the same documentary for daily
wire we're we're going to I don't know
if we're not they're not going to see us
together but we're both participating in
the history of the western civilization
for daily wire so that's going to be fun
yes we're spiritually together even
that's right literally together yeah
because I'm really uh looking forward to
you've got your the Jerusalem episode
right that that will be coming out and I
was I was in Greece so uh that'll be out
soon I think yeah there's a lot of
exciting things happen thank you so much
for joining me today chances have been a
pleasure as ever and they I look forward
to getting together in June and Dublin
Jonathan and God willing we'll get to do
something Spencer I know we've mentioned
Nashville but I don't know logistically
a biography is difficult so maybe we'll
bring you over to this side of the
Atlantic in some stage I would love that
amen that sounds great thanks for
bringing us together thank you yeah
thanks thanks guys